[Music]  the winners and new champions of Dancing  with the Stars are Rashad I feel amazing  like I can't I feel good  truly to come on the show never dancing  the day of my life and just keep on  running and learning how to dance her  winning like I'm her biggest fan  you have no idea going on tour you know  obviously and continuing to work out and  prepare for that call for football how  you going to balance both oh no poor  goal going into the agreement I doubt we  are already mapped out everywhere I'm  gonna be training every single day no  matter where I'm at clearly we would  rehearse like for hours and hours and  hours a day and now we we don't we do  have our show which is a lot of good  great cardio then in the morning so you  know have all this time to really like  put it put energy into yourself  you